for time i just wondered what
non-essential items were in supermarkets
can you give me a couple of examples
so for example electrical goods hardware
goods
and we set these up in the regulations
we also had conversations with retailers
through the week
i joined the chord retailers yesterday
and the challenge is do they understand
the categories of items they need to
take away and to close off
you know a supermarket selling clothes
isn't essential
but we do know though that food items
pharmaceuticals they are essential
so the lists are clear about categories
and we're looking to have a grown-up
understanding with them about what they
can do
so they go ahead and do that because
people do need to use supermarkets to
feed themselves
to use pharmacies there on the high
street but we don't want to get into a
line by line going through thousands of
product items that would be unusable
from their point of view
hours and get some of this message about
the importance of the fire break and to
help keep more people alive hearing
so alcohol is essential but a hair dryer
isn't
look food and drink are items that we've
had through the first period of the
pandemic they're
trust me my hair dryer is essential
no one okay for two weeks for two weeks
we're asking people to do this
a short period of time look at the state
of your hair as opposed to mine i can't
i have to dry my hair you don't
necessarily
you can tell dry yours well
in getting up this morning getting ready
for interviews i don't think that the
biggest issue on people's minds in wales
will be whether they can buy a new
hairdryer not for the next two weeks
you compare that against the figures
that i've outlined on the number of
people going to hospital
the number of people the rising side of
people already losing their lives
and what will happen we're intervening
in people's lives in a way that isn't
comfortable at all for ministers
and what it doesn't and i'm i'm showing
you um or trying to illustrate to you
that you know
what you decide is essential is not
necessarily what other people
will decide as essential